My daughter has been experiencing foot drop, not all the time, but especially at times of stress.
What could be the cause? We are getting no answers.
So for those who don't know, foot drop is when person might be walking in and their dorsi flexion.
So they're, you know, they're toe coming back towards their leg.
It doesn't function properly and the foot kind of just drops and they can trip.
So usually a person that has, if you have foot drop, you're going to often have falls.
That's a form of a taxi. So a taxi is dysfunction of motor function, motor function, muscle function.
So with a young girl having this,
the first thing you should think of is gluten ataxia.
So gluten ataxia is a form of ataxia from gluten sensitivity.
So gluten founded, you know, bread, wheat, spelt, malt, barley.
And the protein is gliandin. So person has a sensitivity to gliandin.
Gliandin antibodies, they eat gliandin causes inflammation.
And you have a gluteal morphine reaction, you have gluteal morphine receptors in the gut to the brain.
And you're going to have inflammation of the brain.
And if it's inflammation, if the motor center is a frontal motor center,
which is this part of the brain here, you can end up with ataxia.
Long story to tell, there's different reasons why a person can have ataxia.
Person can have ataxia from other inflammatory conditions in the brain.
Post cussive syndrome is another reason why a person can have ataxia.
Alcohol consumption causes ataxia.
And the list goes on and on. But the most common for a young person,
it would be gluten ataxia. So getting her completely off-gluten.
And if this, I don't know who this person has this question is,
but if this person said, well, she is off of gluten, then you go,
is it times where she's, then I would deal with the inflammation of the brain.
And also, I would do some investigation, do some lab work to find gluten,
cross-contamination. So different cross-contamination foods with gluten.
Most color would be like corn and dairy and rice and different things like that.
You could test for those. So if you have, I think that's a Syrex array forward test.
It's test for that. If you're not off of gluten now, then for sure you just start with that.
You just go completely gluten-free. That's most common.
I see that multiple times. So it's not an uncommon thing.
I mean, it's a, what do you have? A form of ataxia named after gluten.
Okay, it's a common thing.